Hello, my name is Magnus and I
work in the Developer Relations
team here at Google.
In this video, I
will show you how
to run the Quickstart app
for the Google Drive Android
API, a new API we just launched
that enables you to easily
create great Android apps
that use Google Drive.
The prerequisites to
run this Quickstart
is that you install the Android
SDK and Google Play services.
Both of these can be
downloaded and installed
using the links displayed here.
Then we can get started.
The first step is to download
the Quickstart code, which
is available on GitHub under
the Google Drive folder.
Once you have
downloaded this, you
should install it
on your computer.
Then it's time to build the app.
If you use Eclipse,
for example, you
do this by creating
a project, select
New, Other, Android
project from existing code.
Select the code you
just downloaded,
then make sure to include
the Google Play services.
After that, it's time
to build the project
and generate the APK file
that will be later installed
on the Android device.
Now we're going to register
the app with Google.
And the first
thing we need to do
is to generate the app
signature in the form of a SHA1.
And this picture may look
really, really scary,
but it's actually
very, very easy.
In your terminal window, you
execute the Key Tool program
of the Android SDK with
the command line options
highlighted in the
green box at the top.
Enter the default
password, Android,
hit Enter, and take note of
the SHA1 field being displayed.
This is important as we will
need that value shortly.
Now that we have
this value, we can
proceed to register
our app with Google.
And we use the Google
Cloud console to do so.
The following link
will bring you to page
where you can do this.
In the Google console, the
first thing you want to do
is to create the project.
The only thing really
you need to fill out
as part of this process is the
project name you want to use.
Then select the
API's alternative,
and make sure to
enable Drive API.
By default, the Drive
API is disabled.
So you need to find
it by scrolling down,
and then switch it
to the on position.
Now we're ready to
register our apps which
will have the Drive API enabled.
So select Registered Apps to the
right, and give the app a name.
Then select Android
as the platform
since we're building
an Android app
and accessing our APIs
directly from Android.
The last thing you need to
do when registering your app
is to enter the
Java package name
of your app and the SHA1
value that we previously
generated using Key Tool.
And with this, we have
successfully registered an app
with the Google Cloud
console, and we are now
ready to execute the app.
I will demo the app on
a real physical device.
So in order to do this,
I must transfer the APK
to that actual device.
This can be performed by
connecting the device,
and then using the ADB
command from the Android SDK
to transfer the APK that
we previously built.
All done.
Let's run the app.
So now the application
has started.
And I can go in here and take
a picture with the camera.
That's a great picture.
I'm taking that.
It's asking me to
upload it to Drive.
So I'm accepting that.
And then I can go
over to Drive, and I
can see the picture being
uploaded here, and there it is.
Excellent.
So I took a picture and
it was uploaded to Drive.
And that's it.
We have now installed and
run the Quickstart app
for the Google
Drive Android API.
There's also lots of more
sample code on GitHub
that you can
download and look at.
And now it's all up to
you, so go out there
and create some great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.